la chérie merci d'être avec nous et
merci aux chroniqueurs d'être avec nous
les chéris je vais vous dire j'ai eu la
direction de ses 8 et il va falloir
je vous dis la vérité je doter les
spectateurs on a beaucoup parlé des
chroniques
et
on est en train de réfléchir
peut-être un tp mp en plus un mais quel
jour au cours de la semaine
je raconte tout je vous dis dès samedi à
celle non mais écoutez quand je me
posais pas de questions
j'ai pas dit que vous y serez
on est en train de réfléchir pour
l'instant c'est alain c'est cette
attaque de réfection jeudi au téléphone
qui m'intéresse voilà mais
en argent on passe pas donc on a parlé
que la direction ce matin d'accord et on
s'est dit est ce que les chroniqueurs
serait capable de faire un petit
sacrifice
[Rires]
et si oui de combien de % donc je vais
passer parmi vous avec un petit chapeau
et vous allez me dire à combien vous
pourriez vous faire la prestation pour
une émission en plus c'est à dire pas
combien combien de moins de voir ou
toucher actuellement taz d'accord
bernard montiel moi c'est non
catégoriquement
chez moi le week-end je trouve
ces noms c'est sûr qu'est ce que ça
entraîne si jamais
[Rires]
non alors je te le dire ça ne changera
rien voilà c'est juste on saura qui sont
les mecs à paille
c'est pour rendre service de temps en
temps mais je suis pas sûr non mais
combien alors -11% 20% mais que dalle je
viendrai gratuitement on sait un jour en
plus quoi bah oui c'est pas ma ti va la
faire cette émission
[Rires]
va la faire cette
jolie tmp marche tellement fort cette
année vous dit tout on est je raconte
voilà c'est une vraie info médias 18
heures sony risque on est en train de
réfléchir avec la direction de ses huit
mois avec franck appietto notamment
girac brice viret vont vincent pujol on
est devant un réfléchir un tp mp en plus
voilà dans la semaine c'est vrai que ça
marche très très fort le vendredi ça
marche très très fort toute la semaine
ya énormément d'actu actuellement et
c'est vrai qu'on réfléchisse peut-être
un des pme en plus c'est loin d'être
fait je vous le dis pour l'argent moi je
vous expliquerai
mais ces opus on peut voir voir si les
équipes sont capables de sortir et les
missions en plus parce que c'est en mai
que c'est déjà il ya déjà btpi atp il ya
est la nouvelle émission des mariages
qui va arriver assez rapidement là avec
delphine
puisque va co animer une émission
destinée mois avec des demandes en
mariage je vais voir ça va être très
très fort ça va arriver assez vite voilà
donc c'est vrai que les équipes sont ras
la gueule mais il y en a qui ont envie
de le faire et même dans les équipes y
en a qui s intéressent de de plonger
dans le grand bain de tpm paix qu'est ce
que vous en pensez un tp en plus par
semaine vous bernard montiel a lancé
quelques jours ce serait ça c'est bon
c'est pas grave ça peut être que
week-end ça sera certainement dimanche
moi je remédie quoi quand on sais pas
peut-être six s'étaient présentés par
vous cyril non
[Rires]
les rings bernard qui vous remplace la
maman alors je vais vous dire il ya des
ja normes et j'aurais adoré quand vous
vous ferez ce que vous auriez adoré que
vous présentiez démission pour l'instant
comme de nuit la chaîne a dit non non
pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout pas
du tout c'est je vais lancer le dossier
et après je continuerai à le lancer
[Rires]
[Musique]
je vous raconte tout ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que vous en pensez déjà ce que
vous savez que c'est une bonne idée ce
sera en direct écouter et poser des
questions je me fais chier déjà tu seras
pas toi
ils nous ont bien aimé trop longs et ne
pourra pas c'est une bonne idée moi je
trouve ça parce que les gens ils tous
les week-ends ils vous disent aux dix
mois vivement qu'on te retrouves tu nous
manques etc il faut voilà faut pas faire
le saas et des films qui me disent
mais l'actualité est tellement chargé et
on est en année présidentielle il se
passe tellement je souhaite vous dire et
de le faire vous ouais pourquoi bien sûr
et 20 2% -
bah qu'est ce qui vous arrange 20 % 20 %
des dunkerquois non non non
il ya la bataille mais vous êtes fous
qua non mais attendez médailles 20 %
elle est folle celle là pour ça vous
êtes capable de donner 20 % des mails à
nîmes où l'eau gelée en stock on va voir
ses 20% d'anciens titres je trouve que
c'est une bonne idée déjà alors ah oui
alors est ce qu'on en fera un peu plus
de télé où ce sera actualité sas
important vendres actualitté.com ou fait
de l'asbl année au début avec l'élite
après une très bonne idée on vient des
comptes qu'à la place tu alité bien sûr
c'est vrai donc très bonne idée une très
bonne idée est ce que vous seriez
capable de faire 1 alors écoutez oui je
ferai un petit effort jeffrey obtiennent
5%
je peux pousser à 10 mais vraiment c'est
le maximum que vous pourrez faire si je
peux pas parce qu'après je passe pas
[Applaudissements]
yoplait % vraiment parce que ces dix
mois dont on a zéro pourcent ici
va 10 delphi si je m'aligne avec
benjamin ej qu'on attendait alors du
coup moi je vais faire
c'est qu'on prenne la décision après une
très bonne idée parce que cette émission
est tellement addictives le public est
fou de cette émission donc c'est vrai
que le samedi dimanche c'est un peu de
me joindre non non on voit là on fait on
fait la petite pause au pis aller bat
delphine toi qui dis moi oui voiture à +
10 %
ya pas un truc de favoritisme n'est pas
du tout non non non alors toi tu es
capable de faire dit pour son bois aussi
disent ouais et pourtant sur toute la
collection
automne hiver sur toute la collection de
nîmes et d'accor gilles verdez alors
normalement le dimanche on est payés
plus
2 qu'attaquant je vais vous dire quelque
chose et je vous jure que c'est la
vérité c'est que c'est vrai que on va
payer les techniciens plus il donc c'est
pour ça que les techniciens qui
travaillent vraiment eu je pense qu'il
mérite
pas de frontières
qui seront toutes d'accord avec moi eux
sont d'accord d'être payés plus et le
mérite bien sûr vous autour de la table
voilà le mérite c'est pas non plus voilà
donc je me dis je vais essayer de
récupérer de l'argent autour de la table
on le donne et hors de la table
donc pour l'instant j'ai récupéré 20 10
10 alors j'y viendrai au moins cinq ans
que déjà c'est une bonne idée c'est une
très bonne idée non mais dites la vérité
parce que vous avez envie de prendre un
petit billet en plus nos billets en
moins donné je vous donne à 3 50% et les
blogs les x 11 %
[Applaudissements]
gilles verdez je peux d'ores et déjà
vous dire que vous faites partie de
l'aventuré
[Applaudissements]
non pas du tout pas du nombre à baugy
vérité c'est l'amour de cheryl
exactement aimez votre travail emploi
voilà c'est vrai
j'aurais aimé votre travail ça me
changera il a raison
isabelle morini se moque alors moi quand
je suis lâche des prêts dimanche pour
pas un rond non à condition mais pour
pas un rond j'ai l'habitude mais avoir
du sens que je puisse l'ouvrir je parle
de la bouche même bien sûr maintenant
vous soyez prêtes à l'auteur le club à 0
mais votre question le donnera à des
techniciens allaient que technicien je
peux leur donner ce qu'ils veulent y
compris mon corps mais a peu de chances
qu'ils en veuillent
bien regardent ils voient déjà cette
chose avec leur caméra
mais merci en tout cas pour eux ça bien
là pas mal qu'ils aient acquis ça fait
plaisir et maintenant vraiment donc je
donne alors donc gilles verdez 50%
isabelle à casser les prix isabelle vous
pouvez déjà considéré que vous faites
partie de l'aventuré également
le chauffeur livreur
n'avoir c'est une super idée c'est
maintenant quoi parce que le dimanche
parfois on se fait excuser moi du moins
on se fait chier minois cela m'énerve
alors que d'être gagnée que les trucs de
merde là il a flotté dimanche là moi
j'ai le sou de savage suisse avec le
foot mais ya que de la merde donc déjà
ce soit en direct ou pas pour toi mais
oui mais toi tu aimes bien je vois j'ai
envie j'en étais super pas des gens vie
que ce soit en direct malin ah c'est ça
la question moi j'ai envie que son
directoire dérange pas de venir le
dimanche ici je suis à deux pas
franchement le dimanche soir pour ce que
je fais franchement alors c'est vrai
c'est pour aller bouffer des culs
hamelin a préféré
ce serait beaucoup plus utile ici il
voit pas on va pas se raconter une
histoire
vous le savez dimanche pour rentrer
c'est une galère en plus marre
non six en différés c'est non je
viendrai d'accord assorti en direct je
viens excellent si l'homme de télé c'est
pas non non non
ça n'a rien à voir avec le chauffeur
livreur comme jamais livré hier soir des
aubergines non mais là j'aime pas si
c'est pas si ça en dirait que je alors
marcher et je serai là alors je vais
vous dire moi je resterai là
gratuitement vous mettez juste le
parking et après je fais comme les codes
à arrêter les mecs c'est pas vrai un mot
sur la tête de ma mère que tu mets juste
le parking à temps mais j'ai pas dis que
je râle à tous les dimanches mans ah bah
ouais mais là comme je viens au sein de
la jeunesse tu me tu as besoin dit je
viens ok mais je viens et je fais comme
les collectes 25% pour le 6 25% pour le
pas d'accord 25% propres techniciens 25%
pour la boulangère parce que parce que
normalement le dimanche eric on est uni
s'est payée double ans et ça c'est nous
avons accédé à sion c'est un jour
compliqué pour moi
la vanne faut le faire ça on est on est
on est en train d'étudier on avait
relâché avec ma calculatrice toute la
journée et c'est pour ça que je viens
vous voir en a mis en abyme
l'audiovisuel on amenait du paf pour
vous demander votre contribution pour ce
beau projet bravo oui vous moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec mes camarades
évidemment que c'est une idée géniale
parce que vous de toute façon tous les
dimanches soirs vous souhaitez vous êtes
embrassera vous être complètement
déprimé la corde au cou donc au moins on
sera ensemble en direct on va rigoler on
lance la semaine comme ça c'est et en
plus je vous le dis le thème de dimanche
ce sera qu'à des médias
ce que
vous vous doutez bien déjà de qui va
faire l'émission voilà pour ce qui est
des forces conduit au planton encore
oui alors pour ce qui est de l'effort
financier moi je me mets dans votre ou
moins est-ce que vous allez être payés
alors
c'est là que blade je vais vous répondre
avec la plus grande franchise j'ai
demandé au chroniqueur une petite
contribution
parce que pour pouvoir faire ce tempo
pour l'instant on a du mal à joindre les
deux bouts
quand vous dites on sait c'est lui en
fait c'est la chaîne
la chaîne mais qu'est ce qui grève le
budget exactement qui est ce qui grève
le budget parce que les chroniqueurs on
n'est pas la masse cela plus
même alors eh ben et on doit comprendre
alors je vous le dis on doit payer et
c'est normal si on fait ça le dimanche
les techniciens en plus et w9 il ya
toutes les équipes de production des
équipes de production plus qu'on peut
pas prendre les mêmes et gassier la
semaine nationale parce qu'on peut
parler on peut passer par an ça c'est
pas à eux qu'on pense soyez pour ça
qu'ils nouveau pense à vous alors bon je
voudrais mais c'était ma question je
réponds à votre question elle est simple
et claire et ma réponse sera d'une
clarté absolue absolue
je vous le dis reposez moi cette pose
quelques questions ouais mais dans votre
roues cyril je faire si vous avez une
baisse de votre salaire je veux bien
avoir la même baisse que vous
je vais vous dire
[Rires]
je m'adresse aux français ce soir
ces français qui nous regardent et qui
veulent savoir
qui veulent savoir où va le paf
chers français
je vous le dis droit dans les yeux oh
merde c'est cahuzac et je n'ai pas peur
de le dire droit dans les yeux à tout
les pros toutes les personnes ici
présentes
je ne peux pas faire de ristournes
je vais vous dire pourquoi
je ne suis pas payée sur l'émission à
merde
je suis il est malin les premiers débats
je suis lecteur je suis producteur de
l'émission un lac à tous que quand je ne
me paye pas en tant qu'animateur je n'ai
aucun cachet d'animateur
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît oui
merci merci merci isabelle on avertit
d'une solution oui mais quoi je propose
que nous sommes neuf c'est ça conviendra
furino mais que les neuf devenir
coproducteur de l'émission du dimanche
[Applaudissements]
et moi je peux faire une facture aussi
vous savez jacques était pas en faire
une facture de
votre composition s'est proposé que mais
soyons les neuf plus vous donc on serait
10 coproducteur de l'émission du
dimanche c'est pas six ans
si je joue je vous dis pourquoi changer
une statue à la société mais je vous dis
c'est pas si simple et puis en plus je
vais vous dire la vérité
gardez vos cachets ou sûr vous serez
gagnant
coproducteur surtout d'une émission
seulement le dimanche et je vous le dis
vrai ce que des emmerdes c'est que des
hommes
[Rires]
et tout ce qu'il ya de bon mais c'est
moi tout ce qui est beau bébé
d le plaisir laissez-moi les emmerdes
est-ce que je peux poser une question
bien sûr est que tout l'amour que j'ai
pour vous si vous faites une émission
plus vous le disiez c'est parce que ça
marche bien si ça marche bien en télé en
général c'est que la pub bien oui mais
ma question est simple ou valve pognon
[Applaudissements]
les français doivent savoir
les français qui nous regardent et
français ici présents les français
doivent savoir et c'est une bonne
question
t aujourd'hui je le dis
n'était pas du tout la musique il faut
la
mac user avant même de juger
aujourd'hui
l'émission et le prix d'émission est
fixé en début d'année qu'il y ait
énormément de pub ou pas ce n'est pas
moi bien sûr qu'ils gagnent le bénéfice
des pubs puisque c'est la chaîne c'est
sémites et le prix étant fixés en début
d'année je ne peux pas dire en milieu
d'année ah bah oui parce que ça marche
très fort je vais augmenter le prix des
missions connexes et justement ça n'est
pas non il ya pas de réajustement comme
qu'on vaut ça l'air
non mais vraiment donc voilà il n'y a
pas de réajustement donc on s'est mis
d'accord sur un prix avec la chaîne et
la chute sérieux je peux pas non pas
leur dire deux semaines après ça marche
très bien je me veux ça en plus je me
tends en plus je t'en penses donc voilà
c'est un accord on a passé avec la
chaîne si ça marche très bien on est
très heureux si la chaîne voilà bah fait
le plein en publicité je voulais très
content parce qu'on est une chaîne
commerciale mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas moi qui suis bénéficiaire de la
publicité oui mais si cette proposition
vient de la haute direction notamment
vous parliez de gérald brice viret
franck appietto c'est à eux donc vous
pouvez renégocier alors je vous dire ce
sont des amis
ils sont plus que des amis ce sont des
frères je veux dire quand des frères me
demande quelque chose je ne pense pas à
l'argent je pense au bien que je peux le
refaire je suis bouleversé par vos
déclarations
donc ma question est simple qui est
capable de faire un effort financier
pour que cette émission de surface simon
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle bernard
montiel ne veut faire aucun effort
valérie bénaïm 20% benjamin castaldi 10%
delphine à 6h10 % gilles verdez 50%
isabelle morini bosc est capable de
faire 100 % de risque et de venir
gratuitement mais on hésite quand même à
la prendre
je rigole bien entendu rémois bout on
m'avait dit moi j'ai faut que ce soit en
direct même et non mais oh oui sinon je
fais j'ai déjà perdu 50 % la donc si je
refais 50% je sais plus rien donc ça
devrait pas tarder 50 % à 50 % en juin
d'imagnier mois 10% comme delphine ya
pourtant delphine pourquoi pas parce que
c'est votre préféré donc je me dis que
vous allez alors je suis jamais dit que
l'affinité m'a
pressé maintenant ça devient c'est pas
parce que je dis à delphine callas ou
mort et donc que ça
voilà et d'affiner pas du tout ma
préférée ghonim a préféré vous savez
très bien de qui se dit à l'aise il ay
la bête bien sûr j'avais aimé ce que
celle de rama longtemps
servette sera toujours ma préférée quoi
qu'il arrive ça avis voilà qu'elle vivra
voilà exactement ma chérie et j'espère
que tu seras ma préférée le plus
longtemps possible aux voix la tuerie
oui c'est vrai qu'on est associé alors
il faut arrêter d'être
s'arrête avait que ça
non non j'ai foiré texte parce que j'en
ai pas dormi de la nuit
la dernière fois qu'on en a parlé
j'appelais tous mes associés va pas tout
mais voilà je mets des administrateurs
dans dire qu'il suffisait que cette
histoire du lieu aujourd'hui depuis
quand il est associé avec moi alors oui
on associer et c'est vrai que très très
heureux parce que ce n'est guère son
talent mais on associer sur une partie
j'ai une idée votre intérêt et notre
intérêt c'est de prendre un maximum
d'argent aux chroniqueurs vous me le
rendaient à moi et moi j'ai vos
coordonnées je vous recontacte
ultérieurement
[Musique]
cris en bande organisée à votre problème
et non mais ça y est je vous dire la
famille adams a
fait lire des cellules des deux suisses
un nom j'aime pas du tout à mentalité
pourquoi je n'aime pas ta montagne sa
voix porteuse et ouais c'est maintenant
alors moi moi je veux losail propre et
bien aux gens tout malheureusement vous
êtes salle oui
j'ai décidé de losail propres elle ne
sait pas le chauffeur livreur qui parle
c'est quoi ça c'est là c'est une future
producteurs qui parle je vous donnais
d'oseille propres ont fait la première
émission de co2 grâce d'accord at 8 man
inc revient il vous plaît ça a été une
très bonne nouvelle j'ai bouder me dit
je viens gratuit pour rigoler moi
tu peux considérer que c'est fait en
fait c'est que bouder manche demi
portions à la cantine
[Rires]
bouder que c'est fait mon chéri j'ai
fait bouder donc j'étais à la voile à
awala oui alors c'est ça qu'il faut
faire faut faire la première émission
gras corps non à titre de grâce mais si
le public et orchidée home c'est
gracieux à comprendre qu'ils soient de
grâce et
titre le petit tour de grâce c'est qu'on
va mourir après
la bonne solution entre moi et le
français manquait pas grand chose et si
ça marche bien si le public est au
rendez vous si le public décide de nous
regarder dimanche là ce moment là nous
on renégocie et on dit le public veut
bien le plui kaddioui donc maintenant on
veut être payé ça qu'il faut faire à
combien est un succès le dimanche rip
handball a commencé un succès d'audience
c'est bon alors comme ça on peut tout de
suite évaluer si oui et non ça dépend de
l'heure c'est encore assez si on démarre
assez pour cette somme ils ont ce sera
un succès après voilà faudra monter mais
voilà sept cent mille sans succès accord
voilà donc tu as envie je fais pas de
ristourne mangue à huy ah non on voit
très bien
que je vois qui j'avais
dit je vais j'ai compté pour ça je vais
revenir vers vous d'ouvrir shihan atp en
plus un jour de la semaine donc je vais
rire personnel ça me ferait plaisir vous
avez envie à moi je m'achète moi j'ai
toujours envie savez moi tant que je
suis ici je suis content on s'aimerait
donc voilà juste je suis en train
d'essayer de voir si on peut faire
construire un court de paddle
moi je peux faire des allers retours à
vide mais franchement moi je suis
content de vous voir un bout d'os vous
de voir le public 3
de ne pas voir bernard montiel voilà
donc non non franchement j'espère et
puis surtout je pensais je pense qu'il
ya des choses à faire le dimanche depuis
le dimanche je me fait extrêmement chine
donc je pense que les gens aussi donc
voilà donc je me dis à 19h moi je suis
habite à deux pas franchement c'est un
psychiatre en plus je travaille très peu
les émissions
non mais c'est vrai voilà je ne suis pas
non plus un foudre de guerre
donc voilà donc franchement je pense que
ça peut mal et c'est vraiment deux du
zune pass deux heures avec des potes
avec vous et voilà et puis en plus c'est
tout à fait ça vraiment gracieusement
pour la chaîne pour le paf et je moi je
les ai dit à la chaîne n'ayant je leur
offre ma prestation bien entendu à titre
de grâce
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est bon bien votre choisir si vous
voulez parler dit le maintenant sinon
taisez-vous à tout jamais je veux parler
moi je sais ce que c'est une bonne
d'escapades émission en direct le
dimanche il ya quoi en direct le
dimanche pour dire écoutez moi je
n'arrive pas désempli qu'elle a rien à
rien ça me dit ce serait chouette parce
que la tp mp on compense toujours le
soir mais le dimanche après midi c'est
là où c'est le plus chiant générales de
dimanche
j'ai compris son lycée diwan dimanche
après ouais non non non moi mon cadeau
il est encore plus important que je ne
pensais pas sur moi je m'emmerde jamais
par principe et surtout pas le dimanche
donc moi si je viens c'est vraiment ce
m'expose à des disputes avec mon mari
est néanmoins
cette belle idée finalement
je me dis franchement c'est pas si
gênant si vous venez pas on sera content
de vous voir mais on sera content aussi
que tout ce passe bien dans votre couple
mais bien entendu il y aurait six à sept
aussi avant six à sept ans est sortie ça
fait combien beaucoup de cette
tâche est surtout il a raison 6 à 7 on
sait pas pour l'instant non on
va on va tracer parce que voilà ça
devrait avoir un petit peu plus tard
voilà si on démarre mais pour l'instant
je vous le dis c'est à l'état de projet
ça démarre ajuste le 3 octobre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais vole bien entendu normale a
fait pas un best-of de la semaine non
parce que c'est nul je serais pas où
kwai et c'est ma carrière
[Rires]
franchement tu es encore en train de
faire fausse route toi vraiment c'est
pas ton métier
c'est d'être peu de temps à côté de la
plaque d'ailleurs c'est un béné question
si vous n'aviez pas fait télé vous
auriez fait quoi vous mais moi mon
premier métier chez un huissier ah oui
c'est vrai lucette justice ah oui c'est
du droit et si jamais ça va plus à la
télé au bout de 37 ans ben je peux
redevenir vicié pas demain
si beaucoup ne pourront pas y retourner
dès demain non jamais je fais je le
referai plus j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour les huit questions et là vraiment
je parle sérieusement est-ce qu'un type
et en plus en plus est ce que c'est une
bonne idée ou pas aller au rouet le tour
de table où nous donner votre avis vous
vous pensez que c'est une bonne idée
vraiment oui franchement oui d'accord
sincèrement oui c'est une bonne idée ça
m'emmerde mettre une bonne idée
guillaume non je pense que ce film est
pour sérieux parce que l'émission est
très très fort du lundi au vendredi je
pense que ça peut faire un peu moins ah
ouais d'accord très honnêtement non
serbe il a raison il
a raison ça tient avec l'a1 vers bastia
rennes je pense que c'est une excellente
idée d'ailleurs le vendredi maintenant
c'est très très fort c'est comme la
semaine donc je pense c'est la semaine
d'accord donc vous vous êtes pour voilà
beinheim moi je pense que ce serait un
super rendez vous le rendez vous du
dimanche soir où tout le monde serait
réuni la famille machin et en plus en
période d'actualité politique est super
intense on faire un invité politique
très fort tous les dimanches soirs moi
je trouve ça cartonne en marteau sais
c'est pas mal à percer dans le direct de
19h à 21h à paris comme à gauche
extrêmement fort positionnement idéal
franchement vous devrez faire vraiment
on sait que c'est une bonne idée
j'aimerais essayer qui est un
professionnel de la télé produisons de
la guerre
est donc maintenant possible avec bien
sûr delphine moi je pense que ça peut
faire même des meilleur score qu'en
semaine
jean gracia peut-être plus de monde
devant la télé surtout en la pédiatre
liverpool et moi je suis pour le
dimanche après-midi voie ferroviaire
après le
journal dimanche aprèm de 14 après prix
pour michel drucker
bien j'adore michel 1 mais
non mais non mais alors quatre ans dans
sa manche du tournoi
14 heures il ya toujours un peu mort
entre 14 et pas où est ce que rappelez
vous les rendez vous du dimanche avec
drucker c'était en direct à 14 heures
bien sûr mais vous pourriez venir le
dimanche tout ce que vous êtes ben du
coup c'est compliqué parce que je veux
vraiment vivre toute la semaine à paris
parce que là je commence à enchaîner
vraiment
[Rires]
écouté cette seul truc que j'ai trouvé
pour que guillaume puisse avoir une
aventure avec vous plaît est une
histoire d'amour et gilles verdez est
génial et en plus le dimanche et à de
l'actualité politique le dimanche donc
formidable il avait là moi je suis parce
que je suis une suiveuse et je trouve
qu'on est votre avis est-ce que vous en
avez jamais
guillaume peut avoir raison et en
revanche moi je pense que vous feriez un
stand tout seul avec des figurines en
carton derrière ça marcherait aussi bien
voilà c'est doublement du déficit
[Rires]
c'est pas parce qu isabelle est ma
préférée que vous devez lui tomber
dessus wen déjà se retire j'vais
tensions restent au port aux banques
elle à la blague
je trouve ça bien